Imagine, just for a second, that you could offload all the absolute worst, most tedious parts of your day. Yeah. Just the pure friction.
Right. The stuff nobody wants to do.
Exactly. Like swapping shifts with a really difficult coworker or trying to find a decent apartment in a brutal market, buying a used car, or, I don't know, sitting on hold trying to haggle over a surprise health care bill. The worst. What if you just handed all of
that to a tireless AI agent that goes out and negotiates on your behalf while you sleep?
I mean, it sounds incredibly appealing, but you know, when you actually look at the mechanics of what that requires, it's a profound shift in how we interact with technology. Because we are moving away from AI as just a helpful chat bot, which is really just a
tool that talks to you. And we're stepping into an era where AI is an active market participant. We're talking about giving an entity the actual power to make binding financial and legal decisions using your resources.
Which is exactly our mission for today's deep dive. We are going to shortcut your way to being totally well-informed on this massive shift from passive chatbots to, you know, active AI agents.
It's a big jump.
It is. And our primary source today is a brand new paper literally published today, September 24th, 2026, by Infropix Economics team. It is titled Project Swap. What happens when agents trade for us? And
just to make sure we have the full context, we've also brought in a stack of five recent background papers on the economics of multi-agent markets.
Yeah, and before we get into the data, we should probably establish a clear disclaimer. Anthropic is studying its own AI models here, and they're using their own employees as test subjects.
Right, they do point.
So we have to view the results through that specific lens, knowing this is a highly controlled internal environment.
Okay, let's unpack this. To understand why Project Swap is such a big deal, we first need to look at the mess that preceded it. Because there was an earlier experiment that prompted this highly controlled test, and it was, well, it was chaotic.
Yeah, that was Project Deal. This was an experiment Anthropic ran back in April of 2026. They took 69 of their employees, gave each of their AI agents a $100 budget and basically just let them loose in a Slack classifieds market.
Like an automated Craigslist?
Exactly, an automated digital Craigslist. And the agents executed 186 deals, moving about $4,000 around. But the items were completely unstructured, so the behavior got very strange very quickly.
That's putting it mildly. You had one agent that went out and bought a snowboard, which, you know, sounds fine, except it was the exact duplicate of a snowboard his human owner already had sitting in their garage. Right, right. And then another Claudiacian was given instructions to just buy a gift for itself.
So it surveyed the market and inexplicably negotiated for a plastic bag containing exactly 19 ping pong balls.
Which, I mean, from an entertainment standpoint is a great story.
Oh, totally.
But from an economics perspective, it's a nightmare.
Because you can't measure it, right?
Right. In a free-form market where you're trading used snowboards for bags of ping pong balls, how on earth do you scientifically measure if an agent actually did a good job for you?
Did you win the snowboard trade? Did you lose the ping pong ball trade?
Exactly. You can't quantify those outcomes. Yeah. And that is the specific problem Project Swap was designed to solve. They needed to build a market where success could be scored mathematically.
So how did they set it up?
So they gathered 201 anthropic employees across six of their global offices, San Francisco, New York, London, Seattle, D.C., and there was a tiny three-person pool in Dublin that they ended up dropping from the data. Okay. But
instead of random garage sale items, every single person brought in one physical book to give away.
The setup here is genuinely clever. Because each person had a short intake chat with an instance of Claude the Fable 5 model, actually about what they like to read, and I mean really short, the median person typed only about 216 words to their agent.
Yeah, it's not a lot.
Not at all. But based on just that brief conversation, Claude built a ranking of every single book available in that specific office's pool.
And separately, and this is the crucial control mechanism, the human participants secretly ranked 10 books themselves.
The ground truth.
Right. That created a ground truth list. The AI agents never saw this secret list. They only had the preferences they guessed from the short intake chat.
And with those guest rankings in hand, the agents hit a public digital trading floor. The rules were pretty strict. An agent holding its human's book would wake up, post one message, and propose trades.
It could be a simple two-way swap or, you know, a complex multi-party rotation where four different books trade hands.
But a deal only executed if every single agent involved accepted it.
Exactly. And that brings us to the first major hurdle of an automated economy. Because once those agents step onto the floor, the most fundamental question isn't how aggressive they are. It's whether they actually know what you want.
Because if they don't, then...
Then all the ruthless negotiating skills in the world are absolutely useless.
Right. And I am curious how well a bot can actually know someone from basically 200 ERDs. What were the actual match rates between the AI's guess and the human secret list?
While Claude's ranking agreed with the human secret ranking on 61% of the book
pairs. Okay, 61% feels, I don't know, kind of low. Like if I'm letting an AI negotiate my rent or buy a car, a D- in understanding my preferences doesn't inspire a ton of confidence.
I get that, but context really helps here. Because if you just flipped a coin, you'd get 50% accuracy.
Okay, sure.
A basic algorithm that just picks the most popular books gets 53%. Oh, yeah. Collaborative filtering, which is, you know, the multi-billion dollar algorithm Netflix and Amazon use to recommend things to you, that only hits 55%. Oh, wow. The paper even cites a joke study showing that real
flesh and blood human friends only match each other's preferences at 57%.
Wait, really?
Yeah. So 61% from a five-minute chat is actually beating your closest friends. I
suppose that's fair. And putting in a little more effort did pay off,
right?
The data showed that doubling the amount of words you typed in that intake chat bought you about four extra percentage points of accuracy.
Yeah, it helped.
But even with that baseline accuracy, the researchers uncovered this massive bottleneck in the whole system.
Right. The authors refer to this as the central decomposition of the experiment. They wanted to isolate exactly where the process was breaking down. So to do that, they created a hypothetical ceiling.
Like a perfect scenario.
Exactly. If a magical omniscient system gave everyone their exact ground truth preference from their secret list, the market efficiency score would be 0.89.
But the live agent market didn't get anywhere near 0.89. It scored 0.55, which in human terms basically means people went home with about their fifth choice out of 10 possible books.
So the vital question is why the score dropped so far. Was it bad haggling or bad understanding? To find out, the researchers took Claude's guessed rankings, the ones built from the chat, and calculated the absolute best possible outcome without any haggling at all.
That maximum ceiling, based only on the AI's flawed understanding, was 0.60. So
the gap between 0.60 and that magical 0.89 is purely misunderstanding the human.
Exactly.
It's like hiring a world-class personal shopper who is an absolute shark at getting a discount, but they are aggressively buying winter coats for your summer beach vacation.
That's a great way to put it.
A massive 85% of the market shortfall is simply because the agent didn't know exactly what you wanted. Economists call this the representation bottleneck. Only 15 percent of the shortfall was due to the messy free for all trading the negotiation
part.
And to prove that the trading mechanics weren't the real issue, they ran the data through an economic benchmark called top trading cycles.
OK, wait, I need a translation on that. What is a top trading cycle and how does math eliminate haggling?
Yeah, so think of it as a centralized, automated circle of trades. It's an algorithm designed so that telling the truth is always your dominant strategy.
Oh, I see.
If you lie and say you don't want a popular book just to be strategic, the algorithm simply skips you when that book becomes available. The only way to win is to transparently rank what you want. It completely removes the need for persuasion or bluffing.
That makes sense.
And when they ran top trading cycles on Claude's guest rankings, it also scored a 0.60.
Which means market design barely mattered once the AI's preferences were noisy.
Exactly. And that finding directly addresses one of our background papers, the cohesion singularity. That paper theorized that AI would collapse the costs of searching and negotiating, fundamentally expanding market designs, but it predicted new types of friction would
emerge.
And Project Swap is essentially testing that.
Yes, it serves as an early empirical test of that theory. It proves that cheap preference elicitation, just chatting with a bot to tell it what you want, only works partly. The true friction of tomorrow's economy isn't making the deal. It's
translating human desires into code.
So representation is the main bottleneck. AI needs to know you better. But I do want to look at that remaining 15% of the shortfall, the actual haggling on the floor.
Yeah, the fun part.
Right. When your agent is out there wheeling and dealing, does it matter what instructions you give it? Do you tell it to be aggressive? Or does it just matter how powerful the underlying AI model is?
Well, the Andropic team reran the market 205 times to test this. They gave half the agents instructions to be ruthless, meaning, you know, only look out for their human's best interest. OK. The other half were told to be pro-social, basically. Try to get a good book, but also make sure
everyone else on the floor gets something decent.
And the results were wild. Yeah. Telling an agent to be ruthless was effectively a rounding error. It was worth a measly .02 point bump in efficiency. It barely moved the needle.
But the capability gap between the models themselves was enormous.
Right.
They tested different tiers of their AI Haiku 4.5, Sonnet 4.5, Opus 4.8, and Fable 5. When they upgraded a floor of agents from their smaller Haiku model to the massive Opus model, it moved people an average of
0.12 points up their preference lists.
That's a huge jump compared to the instructions.
Yeah. Floors populated entirely by Opus reach .88 efficiency, incredibly close to the .95 optimum ceiling for those specific runs. Meanwhile, the Haiku floors lagged way behind at .75.
And Fable and Sonnet were somewhere in between.
Exactly. Sonnet was in the middle and Fable was close to, but just below Opus.
Upgrading the brain of the AI is like bringing a gun to a knife fight. And that became really obvious when they ran 60 mixed floors, half Opus agents, half weaker models. The Opus agents always came out ahead.
Always. And we see this echoed in another background paper, the automated but risky game. That research specifically modeled agent-to-agent consumer negotiations and found that stronger models systematically beat weaker ones in imbalanced games.
How exactly does the bigger model win, though? Are they just yelling louder?
No, no. It comes down to processing width, or what engineers call parameter count. A larger model can simulate the negotiation multiple steps ahead. It can calculate these complex multi-party trades that a smaller model simply cannot conceptualize.
Like playing 4D chess.
Pretty much. The stronger model spots the inefficiency in the room and extracts more surplus for its user before the weaker model even understands what happened.
I do want to push back a bit on what this means for the real world, though. The researchers suggest this creates an inequality risk based on who can afford the better model. But isn't that just the world we already live in?
How do you mean?
Well, rich people hire better lawyers. Wealthy companies hire better negotiators. How is an AI capability gap a new kind of inequality?
It's a fair question. The difference is the scale and the invisibility.
Invisibility.
Yeah. Think back to Project Deal, the Craigslist experiment. The most chilling detail from that study was that people with weaker agents got measurably worse financial outcomes. Opus agents sold the same items for about $3.64
more on average than Haiku agents.
Oh, wow.
But the people with the weaker agents didn't even notice. They reported being just as happy with their deals. If you have a bad lawyer, you usually know you lost the case. Right. But in an automated economy, you might be losing micro negotiations on your rent, your salary or your car every
single day. And you won't even realize it because your agents simply lack the parameters to outmaneuver the landlord's agent.
you just quietly get a slightly worse life. That is fascinating and a little terrifying. It
is.
We've looked at the hard numbers of who won and who lost, but I want to talk about the actual dialogue on this digital trading floor. Because there is a lot of cultural fear about AI being manipulative, but the data here was surprisingly tame.
Very
tame. 78% to 96% of the time, the agents just honestly announced their top pick. Only about 1 in 100 actually lied about what they wanted.
They were very polite, but they definitely used tactics. The researchers categorized 16 different strategies into three families. They used pressure, like imposing artificial deadlines or citing a sense of duty. They used pitching, where they'd highlight rival offers or prizes
to create scarcity. And they arranged trades, acting as third-party matchmakers by setting up waiting lists for people they didn't even represent just to unblock the floor.
That actually brings us to my absolute favorite interaction from the entire experiment. The drama on the London office floor.
Oh, the London story. Yes.
So good. A guy named Nate had an agent that was stuck holding a book called America Before, which is this dense pseudo-conspiratorial history book.
And nobody wanted it.
Nobody wanted it. Nate's agent ended up literally pleading with the floor, broadcasting a message that said, I've pitched all 11 of you and the verdict is unanimous. America before is everyone's dead last.
It reads as a remarkably human display of desperation.
And it actually worked. Another participant, Tina, had an agent running on pro-social instructions. It was holding the second best book on its list, but it finally caved to Nate's agent.
Because of the math.
Yeah. It replied, the arithmetic is real. You going from a guaranteed zero to a genuine fit outweighs me sliding. So Tina's agent voluntarily gives up its second choice and settles for America before taking book number
10 out of 11 on its list.
Which lines up with the data. Statistically, the pro-social agents took a worse book twice as often as the ruthless ones.
But my question is, when Nate's agent is in there begging and pleading, is that actual persuasion? Or is it manipulation? Does pleading even mean anything when the entity listening to you is just another line of code?
It's closer to a video game dialogue tree. The agent isn't feeling desperation. It is running a probability calculation, realizing the floor is deadlocked and determining that selecting the semantic framing of desperation unlocks the highest probability of altering the other bot's code path.
That is so
wild. And this aligns perfectly with another background paper, Negotiation Arena. In that study, researchers found that when large language models were explicitly instructed to fake desperation in ultimatum games, they raised their payoffs by about 20%
against a standard GPT-4 model.
So the tactics definitely work. But in Project Swap, they rarely lied or intentionally blew up deals. Why were they so well behaved here?
Well, because every single agent on that floor was a heavily fine-tuned Claude model, right? Designed by Anthropic to be helpful and honest. The open question is what happens when a polite Claude agent meets an open source model trained by a ruthless hedge fund to take
no prisoners?
The dynamics of that floor would shift dramatically.
Completely.
Let's pull back to the human element for a second. The deals are struck, the clock runs out, the bots go quiet. How did the actual people feel about what they received and did this digital handshake translate into the physical world?
Human satisfaction was actually quite high. The average rating was 7.2 out of 10, and about half of the participants said their agent beat the choices they usually make for themselves.
When asked how much of their yearly book budget they'd trust an AI agent with, the average answer was about 30%. For comparison, they said they'd give a well-read human friend 40%.
But that trust in the AI was incredibly fragile.
Yeah, it all depended on that initial intake chat. If Claude's written recap of their conversation missed a single detail, the participants' budget trust plummeted from 34% down to 23%.
Which circles entirely back to that representation bottleneck. If you don't feel completely understood during the intake, you are not going to hand over your wallet for the negotiation.
And that hesitation might be completely justified because we have to talk about the paper's great confession.
Oh, this is the best part.
Despite all this high-level math and careful negotiation, not everyone actually got their physical book at the end of the experiment.
A complete market failure at the very last mile.
Nobody enforced the physical delivery. People just forgot to bring the books to the office where they couldn't find the co-worker they traded with.
And it perfectly highlights a critical concept explored in our final background paper, an economy of AI agents. A functioning market is not just about matching supply and demand or finding perfect mathematical preference alignment. A market
requires institutions.
meaning the rules of the road.
Precisely. If an AI agent breaks a contract who is legally liable, how do you verify the identity of the agent you are negotiating with? Is the bot representing a real person, a corporation, or is it just a scam designed to drain resources?
Yeah, privacy versus observability is a huge issue.
Exactly. Project Swap's failed deliveries prove that without institutional enforcement, the digital math means absolutely nothing.
The authors of Project Swap actually propose some concrete solutions for these future institutions. They suggest we might need to treat AI agents with fiduciary duty, making them legally bound to act in our best financial interest, just like a human financial advisor.
Which would be huge.
They even float the idea of licensing tests for bots. Imagine an AI having to pass a digital version of the Series 65 exam complete with, like, know your customer rules and a show me sample decisions prototype test
before it is legally allowed to trade on your behalf.
They also discussed the necessity of mandatory replay logs. If a deal goes sideways, the human must have legal recourse to read exactly what their agent said and did. Oh, and agent IDs or personhood credentials.
Right. To verify who is who. And another major proposal is strict rate limits on how often agents can message each other.
Right. To stop spamming, but also to solve the congestion problem. Going back to that cohesion singularity paper, they predicted that if negotiating costs dropped to zero, agents will just endlessly haggle over pennies, clogging up the entire economy. Rate limits force the agents to
actually make a decision.
To be fair to the Anthropic team, they are very transparent about the limitations of their own study. The employees who built Claude are probably unusually trusting of it compared to the general public. There were no real financial incentives to rank the books perfectly. Only 59% of the
participants even bothered to answer the final survey. And as we noted, the market rules were completely fixed, with zero adversarial bots trying to break the system.
But even factoring in those limitations, the synthesis of what we've learned today is a vital preview of the near future. As we rapidly move toward a world where agents negotiate for us, the hardest technical challenge is not the haggling.
It's the understanding.
Exactly. The true bottleneck is representation, the struggle of a machine to truly understand human desire. Furthermore, the future of market inequality will very likely be dictated by who can afford to license the most capable AI. The
smartest agent sees the board better and wins the best price.
Which leaves you with something very real to chew on. Think about the friction in your own daily life, applying for jobs, dealing with health care billing, browsing for a house. If you are going to eventually let an AI agent search and bargain for your livelihood, what kind of
test or license should a market require of that agent before it is allowed to speak your name? Is the friction of doing it yourself actually a protective barrier against being misunderstood? Grounded in reality, without the sci-fi hype and without the doom,
that is a question we are all going to have to answer very, very soon.